this is really not how I wanted to
kick-off December so yeah I'm gonna jump
on a little bit of a bandwagon I'm gonna
talk about article 13 which is something
you may have heard about depending on
where you live you may have heard about
it more than other places I'm gonna try
and keep this really really succinct and
like I did want to get my net neutrality
video I'm also not going to monetize
this because I want this as a message
that gets out as far as it possibly can
and I don't care about making money off
this that's not the point
so article 13 is a European Union
regulation that is going to alter
basically oh it's going to alter and
specify the responsibilities when it
comes to copyrighted content being
uploaded onto anywhere on the Internet
and to simplify this as best I can if
you want much more detailed video I
recommend the film theory video which
I'll link to up there matpat did a
pretty thorough job if you want
something in more detail but condensing
it as best as I can what is happening
and let's be clear article 13 has
already passed this is something that's
happening what hasn't happened yet is
the wording has not been finalized and
that's where we're in potentially in a
really huge amount of trouble right now
so article 13 is looking to codify and
make very specific what platform holders
be and you know platform holders are
people like YouTube Twitter snapchat etc
etc etc what they are required to do in
order to be in compliance with copyright
regulation now an earlier draft of it
basically made it pretty specific in
terms of what the expectations were in
order to quote-unquote be acting in good
faith and it was basically what a lot of
them were already doing as especially a
place like YouTube basically the way it
was worded originally YouTube's
internal copyright system that already
scans all the videos that gets uploaded
and Flags them for copyright and then
deals with them once they're up
that would have been sufficient that has
been removed leaving it incredibly vague
and if it's vague
that leaves the copyright holders and
let's be very clear copyright holders
are not the original artists copyright
holders basically for anything that
isn't self-published are massive media
companies it's Disney its Nintendo its
Sony these are copyright holders they
basically then hold all the power
because when the when in good faith is
vaguely defined they get to set the
terms because the law is being written
in their favor in terms of giving them
four grounds for what does or doesn't
constitute a copyright violation what
does that mean in practical terms
well it means that it that now whereas
previously the actual platform's nobody
could go after the platforms for
copyright stuff getting uploaded as long
as they were removing it once they saw
it it was the the guilty party was the
people who uploaded it if this goes
through the platform holder is now
responsible which means it becomes in
their best interest to not even allow
stuff to get uploaded in the first place
unless it can be proven that the person
uploading it holds the copyright for any
and every element of a product that is
being uploaded so I mean I don't use
video clips but even still images have
copyrights so theoretically if I wanted
to put up a Doctor Who video and you
know I put up the Doctor Who logo as in
any part of the video I would need to
express the show that I had the BBC's
permission to do that otherwise I could
never get the video uploaded in the
first place and if it sounds weird that
I'm talking about a European regulation
when I live in the US and YouTube is
based in the US what you need to realize
about companies any company is when they
are working on a multinational scale
when they are working in multiple
markets that have different regulations
no basically no company does it
differently in each region what they do
is they meet the quality restrictions
and the requirements of the most
restrictive market because if they meet
the qualifications of that that means
they already meet the qualifications of
everybody else it's not worth the time
and effort for them to handle Europe
differently than they handle the US and
Canada or China or what-have-you
so they meet the standard of the most
restrictive market which is about two
become the EU and that means that they
that even though I'm in the US this
would still affect me this really
affects basically anybody in everybody
who is not uploading 100% original
content so no video essays no movie
reviews no you know none of that
absolutely like the vast majority
certainly what I watched probably most
of what you watch gone all gone so why
am i who I don't have a huge platform
even talking about this well looking at
my demographics about 40% of my viewers
are in the EU and I did and I mmm I
could be a little I could not I could be
off about this but I do believe that
until brexit is finalized in March of
next year that the UK still has MEP s
these are the representatives that are
voting on this in the EU for this VOC is
this the vote on the language supposed
to be finalized before the end of this
year so that meet about 40% of the
people who regularly watch my stuff have
basically have their equivalent of
getting in touch with their member of
Congress getting in touch with their
representative finding out whether
they're voting in favor of the language
as it currently exists find out why
pressure of them as to what else can be
done and if you don't live in the eeo
the EU and don't have MEP s that you can
reach out to in contact in some way
shape or form then the best thing that
you can do is spread the word so that as
many people as possible hear about this
because I know that people on the
internet tend to we can be alarmist
whenever it comes to the potential
restrictions on what it is we do but
we've been losing these battles lately
we went through a pretty good string of
when the u.s. tried to introduce some
really potentially highly restrictive
stuff that we were able to kill it we
haven't had that best that string lately
and I'm kind of I'm losing my optimism
and I'm losing my faith that we can that
we'll be able to beat it back if we
don't beat the drum and spread the word
and and everything else so if you are in
the EU I and you are and you're a voting
age I would implore you to please get in
touch with your MEP who is going to be
involved in this boat find out where
they stand find out why they stand where
they do and get make your voice heard
they're supposed to be representing you
in some way shape or form so make sure
that they know what you feel and if
you're not in the EU
spread the word as best you can the
hashtag being used on this is save your
internet because this stands to really
rewrite and massively restrict almost
every major platform Facebook YouTube
Twitter snapchat tumblr anything anybody
uploads almost anything on to it's
probably just gonna go away and the only
people who will have the power to upload
anything will be the people who can
prove that they already hold the
copyright before they even upload it
which means the internet won't become
the place that you go to for things
besides corporate media it'll be become
it'll become like cable television
network television it'll become the
exclusive domain of massive companies
and all the creators that make the
internet the amazing diverse place that
it is will be gone again I I'm I'm
really I really don't think I'm
exaggerating because I don't work at a
media company but I do work at a company
that has to deal with regulations in
various markets and this what we do is
we build to the most restrictive
regulations that is what YouTube will do
that is what Twitter wrote that's what
they will all do and if the regulations
has currently worded in the vague way
that they are in a way that gives
copyright holders basically a hundred
percent of the power to dictate whatever
they want it becomes not worth it for
any of the platform holders to even
fight them on it because the regulation
is so heavily favored favored to these
massive companies that hold the car
be rights so remember when people say
copyright holder they're not talking
about the little people they are talking
about the companies that is who benefits
from this and that is who will take over
that to all who will be left and
everyone else could potentially just be
wiped out so yeah that's it and getting
more specific wording bringing back the
wording that was in the regulation
before does not mean it's the Wild West
where everyone can do whatever they can
with copyright it was a perfectly
serviceable piece of regulation before
as worded it has now been vague DUP to
the point that it is ripe for abuse and
if anyone remembers the days of Napster
and and things like that you know that
you give these companies the ability to
abuse the system and they will copyright
strikes on YouTube where abuse left and
right until it got tightened up and even
now it's still not great you give them
the ability to abuse it and they will
and that's what it currently does so I
don't I mean you know whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it you know
the usual spiel but I don't think
there's really that much of a discussion
to be had on the spread the word that's
what I'm gonna say spread the word
because I love what I do this still
isn't my living it's a long way off from
being that but I love doing this and I
don't want to have to stop doing this so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]